[Music]
it's time once again for the Oscars the
show that's only worth watching to see
what goes horribly wrong this is not a
joke Moonlight is one best picture and
the Oscar goes to
crash
oh wow since you probably only saw top
gun Maverick in Avatar 2 this year here
are honest trailers for all 10 best
picture nominees to help you catch up
before the ceremony
from the creator of Big League Chew
which should really come with a Lifetime
Achievement Award and an actor so
distinguished you have to pronounce her
name like this Kate Blanchette comes a
bunch of classical music talk that will
go over your head marinolsa Joanne
falletta Lawrence
visual symbolism you won't understand
and nuanced thoughts on the nature of
power and Prestige that will be ignored
in favor of the same cancel culture bad
debate for the millionth time but after
watching Kate Blanche chat remind the
audience their uncultured slobs for
three hours
cheer as they finally throw the Nerds a
little bone at the end sisters and
brothers of the fifth plate it's time
there's the score for Monster Hunter I
understood that reference video games
are art now sick Jake groom from
director Steven Spielberg comes a
stirring look at the life of Great
American director Steven Spielberg
that's a little self-indulgent but if
anyone has earned it it's director
Steven Spielberg watch old Steve take an
unflinching look at his extremely Jewish
youth
starring the extremely not Jewish
Michelle Williams gels is a waste of
motion full of great cameos family hot
solid filmmaking advice when the
Horizons in the middle it's boring and
one weird trick that makes cleaning up a
breeze get the corner get the corner
Cinema therapisto
you laughed as the menu parody the elite
world of fine dining you chuckled as
Glass Onion reminded us billionaires
aren't so smart you smile when the White
Lotus mock the rich for being unable to
let loose now get ready to say okay I
get it already
with 2022's fourth high-profile attempt
to hurt the one percent's feelings
as Reuben oslin takes aim at social
media influencers Russian oligarchs
and champagne socialists in a film that
struck a blow for the working class
taking the Palm to ore at Khan and a
whole bunch of Oscar nominations now in
best picture and rich people will have
to change right
right
grade two cruise control
from the director of Moulin Rouge the
Great Gatsby and other movies that's
been around so much you feel like you're
in Triangle of sadness
comes the true story of one young man's
rise from obscurity and the Fateful
decision he was never able to fully
leave behind doing the Elvis voice but I
think there's a lot less of it now I'm
glad you say that I hear it all the time
sure Austin Butler's from Anaheim
California but two years later he's
still doing King face you know I don't
think I sound like him still but
I guess I must because I hear it a lot
to the point where his fellow nominees
have kindly asked him to cut it out do
you want Tom Hanks to keep doing his
Elvis voice
the king's leech
prepare for a film that truly delivers
on the promise of its title
it doesn't matter what I think anyway
said in a religious community so
old-fashioned they're still using the
first Queen Elizabeth in the third
example in five years of a living in the
country best picture nominee starring
Francis McDormand she's like a human
cheat code as these women come together
to make an impossible decision do
nothing
right
but you know no matter what the outcome
women be talking you women realize we
are talking about leaving I want to talk
about my horse's Ruth and Cheryl we need
to discuss options for the men and the
older boys it would be a good idea
before we list the pros and cons to talk
about exactly what it is we're fighting
for I want to tell another story about
Ruth and Cheryl this is never going to
end 12. angry Mennonites
[Music]
from the studio that hang on a second
hey Karen yeah it's John yeah I know
it's been a while did you happen to
change your Netflix password
you mean they're not letting you share
accounts and see this is exactly why we
broke up in the first place they
they required reading you have remember
from grade school comes a reminder that
war never changes and neither do or
movies featuring all the required hits
the trenches showings gas masks shell
shock stubborn generals vets you can't
go back to civilian life PPU bang bang
Etc in this epic prequel to World War II
that after 1917 has made World War One
the favorite setting for directors most
prestigious Call of Duty trick shot
montages
oh wow
Street tanks
Soldier Boy tell them
it's a sequel to an action movie that
audiences actually liked so there's zero
chance of it winning best picture right
still enjoy this Victory lab for the
most crowd-pleasing film of the year
that may not have much to say Beyond
jets go vroom but hey Tom Cruise has
pulled out more impossible stunts in the
past and no other nominee courts the
Boomer vote quite this hard the kind of
set it for extinction
maybe so sorry
but not today put your cell phone on my
bar and you buy around I love this song
World War we
watch James Cameron be reunited with his
favorite co-star water in this sequel
that asks us why didn't 3D TVs catch on
again oh right right reunite with Jake
Sully and all his kids because I guess
there's no Pandora and blowout method
including his adopted daughter tree
Jesus they'll all learn to bend a new
element from the space Maori battle evil
colonizers and okay look the full honest
trailer for this one is coming out soon
can't give away all the jokes until then
The Life Aquatic with James Cameron from
Martin McDonnell a director so famously
Irish he was born and raised in London
and married an English aristocrat but
still makes irishness his whole thing
like if Boston were a person comes a
film Americans recognize right away as
an allegory for the Irish Civil War so
long as there are no follow-up questions
about a 1920s cloud chaser who ditched
his friend for the cool table and Colin
Farrell as a real Forrest Gump tie who
also happens to be in love with an ass
named Jenny
in this cozy sweater conflict that the
whole town gets in on because they don't
have TV yet so this is basically their
love Island why aren't you talking to
particular no more didn't you would he
used to be the best of friends we're
still the best of friends no you're not
Pharaoh Got Fingered
from the damn Daniels who brought you
farting Harry Potter corbs
and Alabama's a horse comes the decades
best film about the Multiverse and then
saying something because Kevin foggy has
been trying his best okay in this
absurdist take on generational trauma
existential angst and actors feeding
each other their hot dog fingers where
even if you suddenly learn Kung Fu the
real takeaway is learning patience
kindness and then maybe you should throw
out your Trader Joe's everything bagel
seasoning because it only leads to
problems
yo a24 raps
starring these 2022 entertainment Trends
getting sick
[Music]
extreme class divides
and fighting the rising tide of fascism
[Music]
we really are just rebooting The Roaring
20s all over again huh wasn't there
anything original to this
[Applause]
and Donkey death ah check
Oscars
1995. wait that can't be right the 95th
does he know
if you've made it this far you might
actually care about the Oscars you sick
little freak we analyze the declining
quality of Best Picture winners over
time with actual objective data in an
all-new episode of by the Numbers click
the thumbnail on the right to watch
exactly how why and where it went wrong
and the Oscar goes to man gets hit by
football keep my wife's name out your
Ampersand number Dollar percentage
Ampersand mouth
I would have gotten away with it too if
it weren't for those meddling screen
Junkies
you must gather your party before
venturing forth